you have had such interesting
relationships um with people that like
we all love so much like um B Midler and
Suzanne Summers um and Barbara
strand what comes to mind if I say B
Midler
talent talent as talented as they
come what does she like personally like
like in a room when you're hanging out
funny she's a funny girl okay what about
Suzanne summmer she was a great I I
didn't know she was that ill we were
friends for like 35 years just good good
person good inside um yeah that was a
tragedy I really really uh that was a
really sad moment for me and what was
she like when you were in a room with
her she was just a great person tried to
get me to eat always always trying to
cooking for me constantly cooking for me
every time I came over to her house she
was try to details that I love and what
about Barbara strian she's just the
greatest singer that ever lived that's
that's it I did a doet with her and the
day I had to uh to do my part of the
vocal here's what came
out excuse me when a minute
I I couldn't sing at all so it had to be
that you know I I couldn't do it
standing looking at her I couldn't do it
and then what happened I had him do it a
couple of days later my
part because life happens yeah no
Barbara happens I mean you know I I saw
her at the Bonar you know that was her
first nightclub and me me and Larry
Rosenfeld my uh my buddy from school we
were like uh 18 years old and um she
was
fantastic I'll never forget it I'll
never forget it and I told her that when
I met her and she uh really that's
good